genau drei monate nach zulassung dieser
rolle auf deutschen straßen frage ich
mich schon ob gott das so gewollt hat ja
ich meine nein und an die scheuer unser
verkehrsminister will ja dass diese
teile demnächst auch auf deutschen
busspuren fahren dürfen warum war
überhaupt gast ja und warum mussten
diese sinnlosen e-scooter überhaupt
zugelassen werden ich finde es jetzt mal
cool wenn ich endlich mit meinem elektro
scooter fahren könnte jetzt klar ja
sie mussten zugelassen werden damit er
mit seinen scootern fahren kann plural
der feine herr zehntausende von den
dingern flitzen bei uns durch die gegend
hauptsächlich wird ihnen auch
aufgefallen seien in den innenstädten
leider nicht in außenbezirken wo die
wege zur nächsten haltestelle deutlich
länger sind so viel zum letzte meile
bullshit die scooter zielgruppe sind
offensichtlich ja an getötete touristen
ist die handhabung eigentlich schwierig
[Musik]
ja man kann nicht lässt sich hinfallen
das geht nicht
ich habe es versucht so und was was
viele im land nicht wissen für scooter
fahrer gelten tatsächlich dieselben
regeln wie für autofahrer das heißt über
0,5 promille
und man ist dran ja da gibt es für
einige böse überraschung noch gibt es
keine bundesweite unfallstatistik aber
die meisten deutschen notaufnahme sagen
der scooter macht ihr leben nicht
unbedingt schöner und so wird aus einem
hipster ganz schnell ein gips da wohl
nehme ich das bloß her
die dinger stehen überall im weg rum und
natürlich fahren sie auch
verbotenerweise auf dem bürgersteig hier
ein tapferer hilfssheriff vom
sogenannten fachverband fußverkehr die
rasenden zweiräder stören seinen
ordnungssinn
laut du einfach nur feintuning wohl
jubeln aber ja was jubeln of driving
sideways oyo break the lord william j
wichtiger hinweis von mir bitte googeln
sie zu hause nicht fachverband
fußverkehr sie landen auf den falschen
seiten ich wollte es noch einmal gesagt
haben so einfach mal zu hause nach
google und wer von ihnen denkt scooter
sein ein toller beitrag zur
verkehrswende ja beziehungsweise nein
rechnet man alle emissionen die bei der
herstellung und über die gesamte
lebensdauer entstehen schneiden sie pro
kilometer sogar schlechter ab als diesel
busse aber zum glück das ist die gute
nachricht werden die roller wenigstens
umweltfreundlich entsorgt
[Musik]
wenn europas ausrasten ja oft werden die
armen rolle auch einfach in den fluss
geworfen ist nicht schön
einst hat der scooter immerhin geschafft
endlich gibt es in deutschland einen job
auf denen sogar hermes boten verächtlich
runter gucken können user chooser ja das
sind diese armen schweine die nachts
roller wieder einsammeln und bei sich zu
hause mit ihrem strom wieder aufladen
die landen manchmal bei einem
stundenlohn unter drei euro
dieser mann ihr mann trotzdem das wäre
ja auch eine chance zb für amazon fahrer
also das ist auch ein riesenvorteil dass
sie nicht nur tagsüber pakete aus fahren
können sondern gegebenenfalls auch
nachts dann zusätzlich ihren werden dazu
nutzen können
das gute einzusammeln heben ja was ist
doch super
warum soll man den notarzt zu
überarbeiten
schlafen kann man auch wenn man tot ist
ja hier bewirbt sich jetzt als
armutsquote trägst du den ganzen tag 20
kilo säcke katzenstreu in den fünften
stock
aber du fühlst dich trotzdem nicht
ausgelastet dann wäre doch user und
schlug die ganze nacht folge kotz die
scooter durch die gegend um sie in einer
vibrierenden einzimmerwohnung aufzuladen
nach immer noch nicht ausgelastet dann
werd doch zusätzlich ein fixer es aber
die ganzen verletzten scooter fahrer von
der straße traf sie zu dir nach hause
und drückte gebrochenen knochen wieder
in rosa tiefer kann man echt nicht
ja
witten
ja alles
alles wirklich eher traurig immerhin hat
das verkehrsministerium von andy schoy
jetzt endlich einen eigenen internet
channel zum thema scooter sicherheit
[Musik]
bild aldi
uta von nicht vermiesen schon gar nicht
vom chronisch schlecht gelaunten mit
50ern in den wechseljahren world
zugegeben die sicherheitstipps der ist
guter anbieter sind total öde hier die
original app der firma allein
katastrophe viel zu viele buchstaben
wäre so oft auf die fresse fällt wie es
guter fahrer kann noch nicht mehr lesen
und ein spießer tipps wir empfehlen
einen helm zu tragen
na ja deine mutter trägt nehme
es gibt ernsthaft keine helmpflicht
nein wozu man darf die dinger mit 14
fahren in dem alter ist die fontanelle
noch gar nicht zu gewachsener ist der
schock noch ganz weich da kann gar
nichts passieren also außerdem sagen sie
mal einem teenager der morgens eine
stunde im bad braucht er soll die frisur
mit einem helm kaputtmachen york
also das sind natürlich probleme da
können sie sich nicht so weit denken
aber bitte safety muss sein keine frage
realistisch also angepasst an die
scooter zielgruppe an die bibel wir von
street one mit andy sagen sicherheit
geht vor benutze daher immer ein bier
helm damit so gefahrlos den promille
leser erreicht ab dem roller fahren
erwachsenen menschen schwarzen besonders
ex auf dem roller ist absolut kein
problem
wichtig ist dass wenigstens einer von
beiden dabei in fahrtrichtung guckt
und passt bitte auf das beim shisha
rauchen auf dem roller deinen schlauch
nicht in die speichen gerät folge fair
nicht nichts ist da zu ende gedacht
nichts die teile sind spätestens nach
einem jahr elektro schrott und man kann
den akku nicht wechseln weil er fest
eingebaut ist es gibt nicht mal ein
blinker und wenn ich zur
richtungsanzeiger eine hand vom lenker
nehme mache ich nicht sofort sagen ja
ist ein problem haben wir aber gelöst
drei vorschläge aus an die chance
ideenschmiede vorschlag 11 router mit
eingebautem megafon
ich war das funktioniert auch mit links
zu je 2 ein extra mitgeführte punktelos
ein
[Applaus]
aber in meinen lieblings idee ist id3
die richtung anzeige mit dem up
gespreizten beinen
[Applaus]
ja
ist
[Applaus]
also frauen müssen noch ein bisschen
üben
das geht dann schon am ende macht jetzt
also überzeugt oder lust auf ein
bisschen evans gut im taxi
[Applaus]
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag menschen überall
lassen die ihre dreggsagg michl liegen
und ihr lasst jetzt slx ein beschissenes
ab
[Musik]